for some reason for the past week I've
been craving to go to where I'm from New
England Connecticut I'm like I just want
to go back I have memories in all these
places in New England and for some
reason deep down in my soul I just want
to go there go and check one-way ticket
I'm going to Connecticut and then who
knows
so the plan is I'm gonna fly to
Connecticut I'm gonna get a rental car
I'm going to drive to the old
neighborhood of where I'm from and then
grew up and I had some of the best
memories ever from there because that's
when I was a little girl and my mind was
so creative I am flying tomorrow morning
and I'm booking my flight
now goodbye Miami hello freezing cold
yeah my sister just called me I'm
looking at flights on the planes to see
she can meet me tomorrow morning
[Music]
this is insane that I'm here you know
what so weird
you go to sleep in one study you wake up
in another literally tastes like I'm
drinking a doughnut never have sugar
like this anymore
[Music]
first up Apple store and I have to try
to fight my hardest not to go to my
neighborhood to the karate school to
anything yet in some cases they arrive
tomorrow I need to find a hotel ASAP
because I'm terrified of driving in the
south so lemon found the place to say
yes probably the best room they have
that they're showing the picture says
that I'll take it quick change I'm
actually just going to take a sneak peek
at the old neighborhood yeah ok you
can't see it but that's my house I'm
gonna have to show you tomorrow
looks exactly the same just without all
your Gardens definitely you look really
creepy right now outside of people's
houses
ok I gotta move
[Music]
oh I just need it so hard did I break it
thank God oh good good day sir knee
out
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our old house crazy
that is crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so crazy it's so different is from
[Music]
no it has been seen enough
and right there used to be where the
diner was the reset breakfast
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah how are you oh my god
oh sorry Amanda Cerny and Sam cerny yeah
I'm so happy we saw you in here
you remember doing these
[Music]
I love it
this is my seat i sat here they did my
fastest paper so we would run out of
quarters to buy lunch and Nancy mole
night
used to always hook us up and make sure
we still ate and she still does that
this mirror this bathroom mirror has
been here since I was in school but I
was like this we gotta figure out what
they need though we're gonna get them a
new playground Sam I started a
foundation awhile ago and we were
creating playgrounds at different places
and it was cerny play the play
foundations yeah
bringing it back good teachers strong
strong motivation for helping the
students and honestly they just need
more funding your life solely depends on
you and every decision that you make in
life leads up to where you are so if you
want to get out there if you want to get
somewhere new just get up and do it and
commit and make it happen it's all in
your hands and nothing is impossible oh
oh the nostalgia we're headed to Rhode
Island's
and only an hour and a half drive live
your life and go on an adventure
but don't forget the small places and
the small things we made it to our hotel
room and got Nate helping us out and
what was the quote date
that's the fact
and now massage first off
of Rhode Island's TBD stay tuned to make
sure you guys comment below let us know
what you liked about the video and show
us some love and hopefully you guys get
to travel to places you've never been
before and just get up and do it
I noticed the playground that I used to
play on all the time and I wanted to see
if I would be able to help with
installing a new playground into the
school
[Music]